hey guys it's justine and today we are
checking out this brand new bike by
specialized i'm such a huge fan of their
bikes and this is the new turbo como sl
this thing
is so awesome i'm so excited about this
it has an integrated gear hub
it's got a freaking basket and you can
go about
61 miles on a single battery charge did
i mention it's electric i know it kind
of looks
like a simple normal everyday bike that
is not electric
pedal assist but it is there's three
different modes depending upon how
lazy you you want to be it's been great
because i love actually riding a bike
for exercise
so i can completely turn off the pedal
assist and what's really great about
this
is this can actually carry up to double
its weight
there's little side bags you can get but
check this out look at this look at this
basket
it's built into the frame so when you're
out
and you're riding your bike this will
stay still so all of the stuff that you
have in here
won't spill out look at this
super steady much like most other
specialized bikes if you guys are
familiar with them there's a mission
control app which you can link to your
bike so you can track all sorts of data
i did do a video previously on this vato
sl 5.0 and i absolutely
love this bike this was kind of my first
kind of jump
into specialized bikes and it was so
amazing being able to ride this for the
past year so this is more of a cruiser
whereas the seat on this one i have a
little bit higher so this is something
that i use
more for longer range you can tell the
tires are much thinner on this one these
are way
more industrial we're ready for some
off-roading but like not too far off the
road just maybe like
you know like a little a little bit off
the road this is the first bike i've
ever ridden with an integrated gear hub
so it was kind of a small learning curve
one of the things that i like so much
about it is there's no grease there's no
mess and there's way less maintenance
than geared bikes
i love these thicker tires i feel a
little more confident when i'm going
off-road
after ridden both of these bikes you can
definitely tell a big difference with
the como sl
being more of a cruiser bike and this is
more of a long distance
speed exercise bike mostly because of
the weight like this thing is
so incredibly light like honestly
like it's it's unbelievable this one is
actually well it's heavier
but it's still it's pretty light
considering it is an electric bike and
how far range you can get with this so
this definitely more of a cruiser
so let's cruise i have an order that i
need to pick up at lululemon and i'm
thinking maybe we can stop at the
farmer's market or maybe like
you know the coffee shop and put some
stuff in my basket
[Music]
this ride down here was awesome having
these gears switch
so seamless is incredible the ride is
amazing
we were cruising i love it i just wish
that there were less people here
anyway let's carry on we've got some
beach cruising to do
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
all right time to pick up the goods
to really test this out to the most
santa monica
basic girl needs be right back
all right we have a dilemma i'm so basic
i forgot that i bought
a yoga mat because it was sold out
online so i had to do in-store pickup
so this is gonna be a real test
oh i think that worked i might need to
put this in here
look at that so much i have so much room
let's see if it makes it home
[Music]
back from the ride and guess what
everything survived
in the basket i can't believe it i mean
this actually stayed in there quite well
the girl in lululemon she's like if you
need to come back i can hold it for you
i said i think i got this and guess what
i do
thank you guys so much for watching i
had so much fun checking out this bike
and a huge thank you to specialize for
sending me this so i can make a video
for you guys
if you want more information about this
bike and all the other bikes that they
have in their entire lineup i'll put a
link in the description
check it out and i'm gonna go do some
yoga with my new mat
it's really cool it has like these 3d
little features
marketing it said that that has like 3d
little things on it so it'll help you
with your practice
god i'm so pathetic i fell for it
[Music]
you